ah man oh man I just I just love the
coffee you know I just love the coffee
okay tonight we're gonna be playing this
game called party hard
tycoon the game is an alpha up a link in
the description and lesion over this
game is this game is originally to put
makers that made party hard and though
the game was like a big party in you're
a serial killer and you have to go in
and like kill everyone without like
Lydia no and find out Colin cops
so it's like a spin-off in the same
universe so I think there are still
gonna be like ceracolors you have to
make a sick party and it has to be dope
like at home that's dope okay house
alright okay okay scope compatibility
anta theme choose a theme can I get me a
beer this is vodka you want to go hard
use your vodka people have some fun and
then get into bad mood and we say man is
food and fights lots of food advice
alright we're partying hard okay
personnel I'm going to need this cop for
the haters a waiter of course and Elaine
technician absolutely absolutely I need
Anita hype you know okay babies entrance
fee and less and less paper less and
less paper and let's make it cheap bad
way when it let's blow the star there we
go
thought this party Oh over to you okay
um I have no idea there this is an alpha
so it's like you really have no idea
like what's going where okay we need
some speakers bad but we need some
speakers can I have without there how
much does this all costs I have like no
idea how much it cost
I think off and live you knob just kind
of twirl off your life
okay the item has low efficiency try
pushing off the wall you're not my dad
okay money I want to spend a lot of
money on you what is this like see the
bandwidth thing it only goes one way
though laser stars this is what I'm
talking about baby
oh my god I was like all my money
where's the vodka thing small table
decor oh my what have I done I spent all
my money on lighting oh this is a
disaster psychobabble what have you done
it's okay it's okay just make up for by
playing speakers everywhere you know
maybe the guests will just be distracted
and they'll be like I like this and I've
been a okay well if we're going to have
we're going to have a party right here
then we got a dope this party up at a
holy cannoli what in here it's kind of a
musical are in half a day
wait this one has like zero efficiency
so I'm moving this left care card back
okay this has some good efficiency okay
what an airy speaker
oh no power
Jesus let's use up all the power okay
I need more power how do I get how do I
get more juice okay let's just start the
party rabbit wait Charlie drinks or
something just took up some money so put
this right here
oh this is the room where like all the
magic happens you know where people are
wining and dining and romantic dinner
and nothing yeah chocolate machine oh
Jesus ice cream still why does it take
so much liquid bar that's what I need it
Wow okay well let's start it this is
going to be a disaster don't forget to
serve food and drinks at your party hey
waiter oh there it is right there
hello sir sir are you are you going to
serve people away or what's this guy
gone
oh okay I have to like do this
Jesus hello babies my oh I was like turn
everything on this gets on our way then
okay what is his entertainment don't
forget to engage your personnel where
are you where are you bro oh crap
hurry up server hurry up no God all day
so much poor people but what is what is
Dracula do sir food Oh start a show
right here
oh my god I have to just like keep on
Briz everyone this is the saddest party
of it this is the saddest thing I've
ever seen okay how do I end the party oh
it has people here as people here
okay that party is over
now this guy right there just go do it
over there they want the vodka they want
the vodka okay and what is it meter at
the bottom for who's this guy doing
start a show at coppers oh well now
coming in now
well this is awesome hey yeah get out
bro we need some cash you know turn this
light on baby
this place is off the hook now I know
what I'm doing now I know you actually
got to serve some people so yes get
those tips when we get those tips get
those taps work those tips work the tips
okay okay dancing indented instead to
dent it then dead ant dead ant dead ant
dead ant dead ant dead ant dead ant ant
ant ant ant ant didn't it oh it's over I
guess
fifteen enjoyed 13 oh my god
level one okay you know not so bad not
too bad for a house party you know now
I'm flying I'm flying
choose your upgrade ooh honey just dead
she's your upgrade funks not head what
does anything mean don't mr. Trump cost
a thousand well this place is a dump
hmm
okay we're going back we're going back
punk rock
definitely need that
we need a lot of people oh my god this
is gnarly
how do we get more power it seems like a
power machine oh you can do served deck
or I'll you get more power that's what I
want to know okay we're the personnel
starting alright let's just do this okay
serve these foods real quick before
someone gets here okay this guy has to
go here turn all these lights are they
keep those hips working take those notes
work and ballet dad to dad that a dad
that they're so impatient I know you
should pay this party is insane name
opportunity table that's why is that my
downfall too many tables it's empty I
already talking about brass guys I got
my hit man working over here I got my
height way I'm working out right here
- lights back on and out mmm yeah yeah
yeah what's this guy doin over here
I'm really sure what's going on with
that guy I think I'm losing money can
headlights back on here we go let's hit
this bad boy hello sorry and I want my
shower I said I'm scaring out does it
end it now this is crazy losing so much
money how do I get more people okay good
I at the end the party ok mousex off
PayPal music op 8-ball
maybe I should just put all the speakers
in here just blew their brains away you
know that's what I'll do
I'm going to redo this house and put all
the speakers over there well this guy's
just doing this thing back there no
coffee is great guy and I got a map
there called topless does that do it
that guy this party's gone okay it
should be ending out who is this guy
okay here we go alright I think it's
over right
it's over exit exit get out of here get
out of here okay a lot of people are
thrilled though yeah keep that money up
keep that money out that night
choose your upgrade the country house
yeah so I'm talking about where's the
country house okay
cats AG get any one of these guys my
visitors just showing show some likes
he's into certain spot and serves how do
I get like oh my god okay Wow I have
like no money where's the entrance okay
we're going to bro this past brodo
where's the fog machine I smell cannon
holy cannoli I not have the money
I just put it right in the middle that
crazy
oh my god I just do a lot of cash for
that okay you know what let's just do
this I need some money what this is
going to be disaster hate man get over
here
oh my god this is a disaster I just
don't have the money you guys see what's
going on all right yeah okay here we go
okay I made a lot of money though it is
expensive you people don't know what you
like I'm going to get the heck out of
here what is what does this do I think
this guy's like a troublemaker kick this
dude out he's dressing a little weird
okay got him out where is this person
going turn these lights back on
I got definitely not going to keep the
party going cuz I just lost a ton of
money okay so the biggest part of this
world's ever seen
okay there'll be cops do we get people
right now if it killed yet okay it
should be on that alright that's quick
oh my god how do you disappoint so many
people - there's no drinks okay how's a
disaster okay here I go here we go
how do I just make more money honey this
is cheap
Wise's locked
I need a hype man in eight this guy I
kept this 27:27 sized okay this thing I
gotta sell this thing that's it nine
hundred sixty bucks
oh my god I'm going to die simple bar
$5,000 large table okay I just need a
beer barrel
bro bro and I guess any more speakers
bro
oh my god this is the apex of creation
okay baby I'm going to blow these
puppies out of the water they're going
to like throw up because the sound okay
here we go
here we go
okay lights on yeah baby yeah baby hype
man let's do this these brows got to go
on air come on come on get that money
that I get that money crap
I steal stuff
this is what I'm talking about that
right we just made that money
okay that's good for today that's good
for today the people thinking change
this okay get out of here
[Music]
Wow it will hated that let's just let's
just do this
Wow I could just charge a lot well I
have no money
attacked okay let me get out of here
is there where I can like reset the game
okay oh my god I'm losing insane amount
of money
how do i restart this game this is a
disaster
$1,000 lecture see is 440 how much your
store I have here
7d I guess we just got to do this again
BAM a
1938 there we go
can I put people always go in this room
okay let's just do this I'd like no
money not enough money
Jesus I'm so poor I tank over here and
like this bad boy up em say right there
bye-bye
copper's get in here yeah this place is
popping you know there are no free table
just stupid light a this you come to the
home rack and you look for a table like
you bet I got that I gotta have a tie
okay I'm actually making a profit here
crazy
it's got my party then I got this
okay all right I got it I thought I got
I got it first when is someone gonna
tell someone
I need more speakers all right I hate
man hello sir what are you putting it
out in here need up nice together away
we have you were fighting okay people
were not happy the prison party yeah so
your party although I may be okay
okay I got to go back to the country
house someplace I can afford it's very
sad there's a party I need this guy and
I need this one in this one he the 40
people okay kids thank you wear ties
until it palm skin still in Apple's I
don't really know that much and we sit
trade small table
okay I guess I can do more music right
okay height man should probably go over
here turn these lights on this dudes to
sort of show right here perfect perfect
and once I fight in I'm going to get
them out of here down here so fast you
won't even know what to think I'm
throwing the world's greatest party okay
yeah there's no free tables because it
is so exclusive sorry you got to start a
show
what drink more beer drink more beer
people fighting it now
this is pretty good it hasn't really
been a good party similary like forever
okay
destitute should start another life got
to go back on let's just cut you an all
in the air
now this quarter is poppin okay here we
go okay enjoy Wow three people actually
enjoy my party for once that's weird my
upgrade patient lounge spot oh my god
hundred people I'm trying to make this
the greatest party of all time yes the
hey man and it's guy
okay how can I make this even better
more music
and out of that money my god
- what I do
she's another beer barrel no Debbie
crazy right there right cries and okay
let's just air this oh my god I don't
have the money to do that oh my god this
is driving me insane he doesn't tell you
how much money it's going to cost bill
maybe he thought they were just ignored
it
okay people get in it get in there okay
psycho that was throwing a big party
right now so y'all better hurry up
okay maybe not this party but next one
I'll be able to turn this thing on
not your update your amp day get out of
here
daddy I don't want poor people in my
party I don't want pool people on my
plan get the heck out of here get the
heck out of here okay they're sort of
resting people it's already guys are
doing arresting people you know I don't
want any people and your daddy or get
out of here how you shut down the party
this party is
not making as much money as I wanted it
down
[Laughter]
okay so once I get some people and I'll
be able to next party I bill turn this
thing on kind of expensive Oh again one
person enjoyed it too MUC grid does the
show and raises money cops may take him
into custody and tell that nothing yeah
dead forest whoa
smoking party yo rap party bro I can
fast forward real quick that guy it
looks like I finally got some money here
where's the wrap party you can hook up
or have someone have fun
that's do it I guess
45 people's a lot
who are the puns yet I still know how
the Fonz
so I do the funds come on browse okay
light shows are on God we're making a
cash I just want talk about okay
people get back here I get back to work
what I feel like I didn't make much of
money I think I lost money
I feel like dad all right well these
realist I start getting out anyhow
yeah this place is pumping profit was
very tiny Jesus okay this is a hard game
I got it met this is a hard game can I
sell stuff
I like now money
wait now I don't want this guys doesn't
do anything 36:6 super cheap here but I
like no money
I guess I'll just put this everywhere oh
my god this like the saddest thing I've
ever seen
brah come on this guy's like yeah guys
like make out yeah like just to make
outlaw better
wow I really need to start we start this
game okay okay I really got a cancel
cancel get out of here get out of here
yeah yeah how do I restart this that
rates of money
he was ass basically went out I just
left okay new game okay here we go this
is what I'm talking about
oh my god babe it we're gone
County Fair this is 19 now all the way
baby
thing is you just kind of cover these
rooms baby
oh crap
anyone here
moves up elope that basically just want
to have it so I think where everyone and
no matter where people are pretty
covered okay
yeah okay dope okay TJ control or not
thank you
right there Jesus
okay I need places to eat
Wow okay tiny tables
it's a crowd in here any more power
there's no room for anything okay okay
get out here let's just start this bro
come on browse this what I'm talking
about okay just just some good lovin you
know everyone's gonna be like this is
the greatest party that has ever existed
I have 61 beans you guys trapped he's
trapped into drinking that's how I feel
at times
okay do I make like any money I know and
I can't tell if I did get
well this made no money
arrest is payable arrest them you get
out of here get more people okay we have
plenty of drinks per day
you guys are fighting get the heck out
of here
perfect perfect
I'm going to be rich Oh a couple of
Fighters huh
get out of here guys chat to rapper
ok let's end this party all right good
they're good she wants profit I got Oh
Lots a lot of money lost a lot of money
ok he's a good boy ok kind of a kind
right house
I can't spread oh ok legs a lot here no
no no no the squat cacked and party had
the rice
there we go that is again first thing I
do is get rid of 17 okay this would be
the last part of the evening I guess and
Tatas okay this kind of gout no one
wants that changes how do I get more
power deck or what if Tendo
brah
there's nowhere to put this rug
I have no choice but to put this palm
tree somewhere here $4,000 for an awning
flamethrower bro Oh cow oh crap
yeah bro chicks love the stop signs I
don't even know what a bow cal is let's
do this I spent like all I money on
stupid decorations okay that's gonna
make sure the food is good people love
this holy crap they're like wow this
stuff is so great like how do you afford
us and I say I don't I lose all out of
money by party okay uh I already gone
okay can't collect the tip too well
faster bye bye
this is the most ravishing parties you
have ever seen
this guy is like in love he's like hey
ladies why not come to this party
oh wow
leave a cop some fun change the part a
girl in bed pay as long as those money
coming in you better keep that party
going get on a trade tables this I wish
you could level up the server
Abby dope hype man get back in there
hello get that crowd lights back on
okay the party never stops not with
psychobabble the party never stops I
need more money baby I named our money
okay when do I gotta start resting
people that's what I got to find out and
those people are in love it's like
really cold so it gets murdered
that would pay my love it's like don't
you get it
the party never ends bad Bay this guy's
doing a up side I think it loves it so
much they think it's a flame power the
flamethrower really doesn't just thumbs
up all around better
thumbs up all around you like that baby
all right see if I lost money whoo I
made money that is what I am talking
about Yakuza New Year are you crazy
house party oh my god how many think am
I doing here
okay well I'm this is today we got a
little taste of it very cool game wish
you can - now for now we can make some
more improvements good direction all
right thank ya what does red mean anyway
how do